welcome to the heavy spoiler show i'm
your host paul and it's time to pull
your head out the sand and get with the
program cause there's a lot to talk
about with westworld season four has
just hit the midpoint with its fourth
episode flipping everything on its head
and throughout this video we're going to
be breaking down the twist talking about
the easter eggs in it and all the hidden
details that you might have missed this
is the super spoiler event of the year
so if you haven't checked it out then
check out now now i want to get straight
into it and up top i think we should
discuss the big twist at the end of the
entry come the closing few scenes it's
revealed that caleb's entire story is
just a fidelity test carried out by hale
on a copy of caleb in the future she has
already won and is simply putting him
through the motions to see if she can
finally establish a baseline the episode
is titled generation loss and this
carries a couple of meanings with it the
first one that pops up is the phrase
itself which has several ties to
photocopying and computer technology
generation loss refers to the loss in
quality between subsequent copies of the
same thing for example if you photocopy
something though it takes the majority
of the data from the original piece
there are certain aspects of it that
aren't duplicated if you photocopy this
photocopy it's then missing those pieces
and the next piece has its own losses
which are then passed on to the next one
once you copy something enough times it
eventually loses so much that it's a
fraction of its former self which is
ties to the temperance park caleb and
just humanity in general who we see are
subservient come the end of the entry
everyone is now just on a loop setting
up christina with dates and watching the
more be of the more millennium aka
mobius now there's also the generation
loss meaning that caleb has lost a
generation so yeah admit it you wouldn't
have spotted that without me would you
chump see you chump
anyway though it initially seems
complicated this reveal at the end
actually simplifies the show quite a bit
in the past we've had timelines that
look like a jackson pollock painting but
this reveal tells us that the majority
of the show is all happening at the same
time whilst caleb's fidelity test is
going on we have bernard meeting up with
his daughter frankie and probably
christina off in the new york storyline
we'll talk about how this could be
happening at a different time due to
what maya says but most of caleb and
maeve's storyline can be put down to
just being flashbacks in the test the
only real parts of the season that are
happening in the past are the william
moments at the dam the golf course and
when hale was interacting with the real
one in the machine now this could also
be the present and it makes me think
that they can put humans in the stasis
and preserve them which i believe will
mean that we'll get the man in black
popping up in the future well well the
present-day storyline the first hint
that this is a montage of caleb's life
comes with us opening on the mission to
the lighthouse that both he and may have
carried out the prototype hyper herbin
was built by the soraks and it was shown
to us earlier in season 3 after we met
the final one at insight a vision of
this first appeared in maeve's vision in
episode 1 but we get it expanded on much
more here now riobum was very much seen
as something that controlled free will
this machine used a complex algorithm to
plot out a course for humanity based on
the data that was obtained at westworld
it put people into specific roles
recommended that certain ones shouldn't
have children and overall it stopped
them from advancing so that its vision
of the future could come to fruition it
was seen as something that controlled
free will and in many ways people became
stuck in loops just living out their
daily lives unable to change or take a
different course however people did
still have free will in many ways as
they were able to act against this and
break free of the system which was
demonstrated in caleb this idea of free
will is always a question in the
parasites that hail develops however
whereas people could break free in the
case of rehobem judging by what we see
in new york at the end this is
completely stripped from everyone they
also have to follow the commands given
by the tower and everyone is under
hail's complete control now during the
mission to rehobem maeve messes up one
of the security cameras as a distraction
and she did something similar at the
senator's house in episode 2. they
planned the explosives and detonate them
and managed to just make it out but
caleb is shot outside early on in our
breakdowns we did question whether this
would be his actual death and it was a
nice fake out for the real one that's to
come later on this very much foreshadows
his quote-unquote death at the end of
the episode and really nice job guys now
during this moment maeve shows caleb
what freedom is by hacking into his
implant we see her walking through the
fields with her daughter wearing the
white dress that she had on in her
original loop in the park there's also
the tree there that was shown last week
which ended up burning as bernard came
across it it's clearly hitting at
maeve's end game and she wants nothing
more than to get back with her daughter
caleb is saved by maeve but we'll talk
about how this works in the story later
on in the video and we kept from this
fantasy to hail waking him up this is
very much how most of the fidelity tests
began and in the case of james delos it
was very much like he woke up and just
got ready hale also appears wearing
black in this scene similar to how
william did when he was carrying out the
fidelity test himself i also love the
subtle moment here where she predicts
the end of caleb's question
my family
did you kill them no they're still
somewhere out there alive
this is a great little detail as we
learn with james delos that william had
an entire conversation that they'd
played to several times we did the arise
earlier in the season that she had
perfected this and that the william host
was actually a direct copy of the real
one though we still don't have it
confirmed i do think it's the case
because he had his childhood memories
and he also has the vendetta against
maeve which he wouldn't have if he was
just impersonating him anyway moving on
from that as i'm probably doing your
head in with it we discover hale's plan
for the park the entire thing was set up
as a way to create carriers for the
parasite which would then garden in the
world and infect people there's lots of
curved illusions here such as the term
super spreader and also the one first
wave being used now hail also explains
why she brought him back and is running
through the fidelity test
maeve and dolores were always so fond of
you i'm inclined to keep you around
see what all the fuss is about it's also
a nice little bit of set design here too
as we can see that the light fittings
used also resemble the tower which was
carried into the street light design in
new york now it's three
air time
pretty much everything is a theory but
that's what we do with the channel
i'm starting to think that these
themselves are mini towers like what we
see on the lamp posts and building
towards the end and having these
throughout the entire city would mean
that hail has complete control over
everyone when fighting against william
maeve ends up hacking into the system
and she then turns up the vibrations to
critical level which not only works
against the hosts but it also destroys
all the glass on the floor maeve also
meets the sound for herself and she
becomes an affected by it now we're
dropping off finally predictions in
already but i kind of have the feeling
that maeve might end up destroying the
tower this way if she can hack into the
giant structure and overpower it it
would potentially destroy all the hosts
caleb doesn't seem anywhere near as
affected as they are and therefore the
humans might be absolutely fine now
maeve is also described as a weapon by
bernard and due to them digging her up
later on it's clear that she's a crucial
part of taking down hail therefore i
think this scene is showing she will be
the key to destroying the tower due to
her control of electronics also if this
did happen yeah we get that we get a
cool shot of all the glass on the
skyscrapers exploding which i just think
would be great anyway that's the end of
theory time every time still gonna be
doing non-stop theories in the video i
just wanted a dedicated section for this
bit of time
now after maeve reunites with hale she
brings up wyatt which was the evil and
homicidal maniac side of dolores that
hail has clearly gone beyond we get a
shot of the flies and i love how their
meaning has mutated throughout the
series initially they were used
symbolically on the host to show them
gaining a higher form of functioning
whereas here they symbolize the downfall
of humanity whilst the hosts grow even
more cut to christina waking up which
again is iconography that has been used
on both her and dolores throughout the
whole series we see her painting
vanishing point has been covered up and
this painting was something that she
used to create in the park as part of
her loop however she shows here that
she's breaking out of it in this new
world by scribbling the tower across the
center of it this being placed over the
painting of the manhattan streets of
course metaphorically showcases that the
tower also controls new york now maya
also talks about a nightmare involving
being swarmed by flies on a family
picnic when she was younger this very
much comes across like it's a repressed
memory but when hale let the parasites
free because this nightmare comes from
when she was younger it seems to plant
this as being roughly at the same time
that the stories involving bernard and
caleb are also happening you also get
this line does it look like anything to
you
which is of course calling back to the
times that it was said by the hosts when
there was something that they weren't
meant to see
doesn't look like anything to me
it doesn't look like anything to me now
this is somewhat murder maya who doesn't
even acknowledge the tower even at the
end of the scene she tries to look at it
but at the last second she looks away
almost like she's scared of seeing the
truth the drawing of the tower also
looks very similar the one by the
homeless man from the first two episodes
my guess is that much in the same way
that rehoboam put people on loops that
all of the citizens of new york are on
one too the man is probably homeless
because either he's immune to the
parasites or he didn't get infected this
would mean that he wouldn't be able to
gel with the other humans on their own
loops and therefore he couldn't fit into
society makes you wonder where christina
fits into it all too and i think that
she is right in the loops of the people
which is why peter went to her in the
first episode in episode 2 she
discovered a wing named after him in
hope hospital that showed he'd been dead
for a number of years my guess is that
this loop was written a long time ago
and then given to him which led to the
original one's death this loop was then
picked up by hail and reused on a
different human much in the same way
that the park would replace hosts when
one went faulty like how clementine did
i do think that christina is a host and
that she'll be revealed to be a copy of
dolores which hale would have access to
due to her being a copy too she later
talks about how she can just make
another man in black so that would be
the same thing here i'd imagine anyway
let's send a theory
so you've already done it i know out
with bernard we hear the talk of
outliers
that was before we found another outlier
we gotta extract her fast before she's
hunted down we can't waste time on some
misguided treasure hunt this was
terminology used in the third season to
discuss people who didn't fit into
rahubam's plan they were ostracized and
sent for reprogramming which we saw
through the story of caleb you also
don't know who this outlier is but i can
imagine it's likely christina due to her
unearthing what's really going on
outliers were people who were
unpredictable that broke free of their
loops and caleb was a human one whilst
dolores was a host one i'm guessing the
term here means people that weren't
affected by the parasite and thus
they've had to band together as rebels
in order to try and save the rest of the
world lots of similarities to the matrix
and we know due to the two hosts in the
parking lot last week that hale is
hunting them down there's also a drone
scanning the area and we hear frankie's
nickname is c nice way of them hiding
the twist i'm guessing that c stands for
now stands for chump or caleb probably
which in hebrew means faithful brave and
bold bernard also hints that stubbs is
going to be useful to the rebels that
he's taken with
i have to go with him for safety at
least i'll be safe
i didn't mean yours
out in the desert we get a really cool
drone scene where they use camouflage to
blend in with the sand and i got a lot
of two towers vibes from this bernard
wanders out into it and he's saved by
frankie at the last second now this was
in order to see if a beetle was there
which actually appeared in his vision
last week this also appeared alongside
temperance looking dusty and run down
which i'm guessing is what the park
looks like now due to it being abandoned
jump back to temperance and caleb's
flashback and we see a copper holding up
hector's wanted poster you met this
park's version of hector last week and
made of course had somewhat of a
relationship with the one in westworld
the three attempt to make a daring
escape from the park and we see how the
parasites have infected people within
temperance itself keeping up with the
matrix analogy this very much turns them
into agents that begin to hunt the pair
as they escort hail out caleb says that
they just became public enemy number one
a term that originated from the 1930s
when it was coined by the fbi hunting
gangsters in settings like this knowing
the loops off by hard maeve is able to
navigate away for them to bootleg a
vehicle which is stocked up with
moonshine during the 1920s prohibition
era america banned the manufacturing
sale of alcohol and thus black market
dealer and gangsters had to create
home-brewed stuff like moonshine which
they ran as bootleggers now we slowly
see the controls start to seep into
caleb's mind as he picks up one of the
guns and points it towards maeve she's
saved by someone stabbing him and this
injury is somewhat similar to the one he
sustained at the start which allows them
to talk about what happened after the
lighthouse mission elsewhere christina
is out on another date and in a call
back to dolores's and teddy's loop
lipstick ends up getting dropped which
he picks up obviously it's a mirror in
the can
obviously you don't need me explain that
to you you in fact you probably know
more than me when it comes down to it
funnily enough loads of people last week
left comments predicting that frankie
was the woman bernard and stubbs met and
it made me look like a right chump
however i still make the big bucks from
doing these mediocre videos on the show
so who's the real chump here you are see
you chop anyway on the day teddy talks
about the mundanity of life i'm sorry
guys i love yous now on the day
oh on the day teddy talks about the
mundanity of life and how he used to
live day to day
rinse and repeat
like a
like a train circling the smallest track
during westworld season one teddy began
his loop by riding into town on the
train but this conversation shows that
he's broken out of it he also mentions
that he was a bounty hunter with a heart
of gold confirming that he indeed had
the same role that he did in the park
and this could be a case of him being
the exact same version as how he was in
westworld or potentially it could be
referring to the grand theft auto-esque
bounties that caleb used to carry out in
season three leaning more towards the
park in all honesty and that would make
sense why he's out there trying to save
dolores now caleb was taken to hospital
by maeve and sitting by his bedside she
saw the finality of life guess she
forgot about lay size moy but she saw
the love that caleb and his wife had and
decided to set him free she wanted him
to actually have happiness and something
to fight for instead of just fighting
she let him be free of the war and fled
into the wilderness allowing him to have
a daughter in life one day she reached
out through the grid to find him and
this is what overcharged the radio at
her home i was kind of hoping that the
radio at her cabin would be linked to
the one with frankie but alas turns out
it was not all connected now through
doing this hale found caleb's family and
this is why she copied his daughter they
then make it at the outskirts of the
park which we see is set up to be
demolished as part of the expansion
program at this point the man in black
arrives once more leading to a shootout
with william and maeve there's more
misses than the jokes in this video and
in the observation room caleb ties up
hail as the pair duke it out this point
the tower is sounded off and hale orders
caleb to shoot maeve however he
overpowers this programming which could
be another reason why she wants to study
him if she can figure out how he
disobeyed her she can potentially
control the outliers kayla very much
hints that he did this because he has
something worth fighting for aka his
family we heard from his team are still
alive after she's stabbed by william
maeve ends up arming the explosives and
she sacrifices herself to take out
william now it's at this point that we
see the truth of the matter with hale
very much appearing like she's running
the fidelity test going through his
memories it's revealed that he died and
we also get this nice bit of editing
that shows frankie is his daughter
before the final reveal frankie will not
grow up in a world
where she is controlled
by you
caleb is then killed by hale's men who
arrive in the security uniforms carrying
the p90s cheers everyone who corrected
the gun mistake on the last video you
guys are the real heroes now elsewhere
bernard starts to dig and we discover
frankie is in fact looking for her
father his body was recovered early and
i know i dropped these videos early so i
can't really see what the fan theories
are before making them but i can imagine
that there will be people who think he's
actually still alive if this stasis
theory about william was right before
then he could have been captured by hell
healed and then put on ice however i
don't think that's the case as hale
refers to him as the 278th version of
caleb still though the original could be
locked up somewhere like william as we
know you don't have to kill someone in
order to copy them i do still doubt he's
alive though but i thought i'd just
explore that in case it's something
people are wondering now we learned that
hale found that the older a person was
the more difficult that their mind was
to alter with the parasite however
infecting children allowed them to grow
in symbiosis with the parasite and
within a generation hale had control big
head moment and we could to caleb coming
too whilst bernard brings maeve's head
out the sand over the top of this is the
demolition sign which we saw when she
and caleb entered the area might be a
reach but maeve being brought out
reminded me a lot of her being built by
sorak in the real world during season
three caleb ends up playing into new
york in an almost captain america-esque
man out of time scene in which he
escaped shield headquarters and fled
into the street as he exits the lobby we
see that he passes the olympiad sign
which you might remember us pointing out
in the first episode had a lot of
similarities to the delos logo leaving
the building we can see that this is
actually the same one that christina
went to work at in the first episode
potentially showing how their paths
might cross we did have theories that
this might indeed be its own park but i
feel this kind of negates all that
however there was that weird
conversation in episode 1 in which
people talked about it being one of the
group's first time so [ __ ] knows really
place is [ __ ] wild you believe this
is your first time
going a bit off the deep end with what
we know now i'm kind of wondering
whether this might be a park for the
hosts for them to come and basically
have their own west world with humanity
i think that would be a super creative
twist but i don't know if they've got
enough time to flash that out but just
kind of spitballing going off what those
three guys said back in episode one that
we haven't stopped thinking about
another weird thing is that there's no
kids in this new york which might have
some significance with hail not allowing
people to breed way back in season three
when we got the simulation by rehobem it
said total population collapse within 23
years which might have come true if hail
has actually stopped people having kids
also this idea of it being a new park is
seen when caleb shielded barges someone
which was something that always happened
whenever people entered one it popped up
in westworld for teddy and william and
in temperance when caleb got off the
train the entire city is then frozen
like the program being posed in the
matrix and it shows that hale has
complete control over absolutely
everything she's won big w and i kind of
hope that caleb ends up pairing up with
christina in order to take this all down
if our theory about mei being used as a
weapon to destroy the tower is true then
this could be how frankie and minado
brought in and it's such a good ending
with so many possibilities this could
honestly have been the end of the season
it's that big of a cliffhanger and i
can't wait to see what happens next week
i genuinely think this was one of the
best westworld episodes ever and it had
one of the biggest oh moments in the
show for me it's up there with realizing
bernard was a host and yeah a really
really good twist to show that hale has
already won and caleb is just going
through a fidelity test brilliant and
i'd of course love to hear your thoughts
so make sure you comment below and let
me know i know some of you are going to
be like it
it sucks paul what the hell are you
talking about but i'd love to hear your
opinions so make sure you drop them
below if you want some emails to watch
then make sure you check out our
breakdown of last week or the boys which
is linked on screen right now we've got
lots of things to talk about definitely
stick around on the channel and make
sure you subscribe and like the video if
you had fun without the way thanks for
sitting through it i've been paul i'll
see you next time take care peace